[Aplausos]
que honra aqui hoje que honra poder
conversar com vocês eu já palestrei para
diversos públicos
mas hoje sem dúvida é muito especial
porque é o meu primeiro tedx x é um
honra aqui hoje com vocês então poder
falar um pouquinho e passar um pouco
dessa minha trajetória e sem dúvida não
vai faltar educação para nós falarmos
quando começarmos eu queria que vocês
pudessem fechar os olhos de vocês
retornar à infância e lembrar de algo
maravilhoso que vocês vivenciaram dentro
da escola
o algo que tenha de fato marcado a vida
de vocês
abrindo os nossos olhos
neste momento eu posso falar com certeza
que o que me marcou foi a educação
por isso que hoje eu quero fazer um
convite pra vocês para que todos aqui
possamos nos tornar ativistas em prol da
educação porque sem dúvida cada um de
nós carregamos uma escola e essa
educação quem ela preparasse o mundo
eu tive uma trajetória de muita luta
tive uma infância difícil sua caçula de
três filhas mulheres criadas somente por
mãe e minha mãe se separou numa época
que mulher não se separava em 1980 um eu
passei a minha infância ouvindo que eu
não seria ninguém que eu enxerguei a
casa da minha mãe de filhos um grande
preconceito
no entanto quis mudar um pouco essa
história apoiado essa grande mulher que
não está mais entre nós mas que fez eu
ser uma das dez melhores professores do
mundo que foi a minha mãe
e durante essa trajetória de luta
eu enxerguei na educação a possibilidade
de mudar a minha própria história porque
eu acredito que nessa escola que a gente
descobre o mundo
foi nessa escola que eu me reconheci
como pessoa e que eu passei a entender
que eu era uma pessoa que eu podia fazer
coisas incríveis então educação ela
perpassa alguns muros e ela permite que
possamos ser o que quisermos
por isso que eu falo que cada um de nós
carrega uma escola porque por mais que
hoje
vocês não estão estudando ou estão vamos
ter filhos vamos ter parentes vamos ter
alguém pra apoiar dentro da educação
então vamos levar de forma formal ou
informal
essa educação adiante nessa educação que
ela é uma vivência de troca
eu não acredito na educação tradicional
mas eu acredito numa educação que a
gente possa vivenciar que a gente possa
enxergar o ser humano
do jeito que ele é nesse momento de
troca por isso ao longo da dessa minha
fala dessa curta fala eu vou trazer
fotos dessas crianças dessas crianças
que eu convivo há seis anos crianças de
uma comunidade carente da cidade da zona
sul da cidade de são paulo
crianças que num pensamento básico que
residem em casas muito simples casas de
madeira e que por muitas vezes ouviram
um que eles não eram capazes
imagina você chegar numa escola ser
professora de mil crianças e você tem
80% dos seus alunos não se achando que é
capaz dentro da escola é uma realidade
muito triste
uma realidade que precisava ser mudada
então essa troca que a gente vai fazer
essa educação diferente é olhando no
reconhecendo essa colaboração é simpatia
mas principalmente essa troca é que a
gente muda de fato uma sociedade
[Música]
e aí eu trouxe uma pergunta pra vocês
que escolheu essa que nós carregamos que
escola é essa que nós temos hoje
o que buscamos eu posso falar com toda
certeza que durante essa minha
trajetória que a escola que eu busco
hoje é uma escola transformadora capaz
de realmente reconhecer esse ser humano
e da voz pra ele fazer de fato ser
protagonista da sua própria história
quando iniciei o trabalho de robótica e
houve muita crítica
primeiro por ser mulher a mulher mexendo
com tecnologia e humanas ao que você
está fazendo com essas crianças é
artesanato
não isso não pode ser robótica
o que me fez seguir em frente não
desmotivar naquele momento foi olhar
para o rosto de cada criança entender
que eles são um ser humano fantástico e
depositar altas expectativas
o trabalho de robótica então nasce para
transformar a vida de crianças jovens da
periferia de são paulo para dizer pra
eles que não é o lugar que determina que
eles podem ser na vida são eles e desta
forma nós já retiramos em três anos e
meio de trabalho
uma tonelada de lixo das ruas são paulo
e transformadas em protótipos mas eu
falo para eles vocês não estão
aprendendo robótica
vocês estão aprendendo em intervir na
sociedade porque é isso que nós estamos
buscando pessoas que possam intervir na
sua própria história
e aí a gente vai ver então sempre essa
escola que a gente carrega se
encontrando
porque essas crianças isso foi tão
poderoso pra eles é o fato de eu
acreditar neles que eu já tenho criança
sonhando coisas que eu não tive
crianças sendo capaz
de e correr atrás dos seus sonhos esse
ano eu tive meu primeiro aluno
ingressando na usp em física não é pouca
coisa
quando a gente pensa que essas crianças
[Aplausos]
obrigada
não é pouca coisa quando a gente pensa
que quando eu comecei
eles não tinham sonhos e hoje eles
descobriram que eles têm os espaços dele
que essa educação transformadora e essa
escola então o que a gente quer é uma
escola capaz de trabalhar resoluções de
problemas reais de olhar para o problema
como nós e como eu encontrei foi o lixo
e transformar isso em currículo
principalmente porque nós estamos no
século 21 o que essas crianças precisam
é ter colaboração é tem empatia é
trabalhar essas relações sócio
emocionais é fazer desse menino a porta
de entrada para que outros olhem para a
própria vida e também sejam
transformadas através da educação
quantos de vocês aqui não teve a vida
transformada pela educação
a educação é transformadora
por mais que vocês não tenham essa
percepção neste momento em algum momento
vocês vão lembrar um puxa isso me marcou
muito e é isso que a gente precisa
buscar enquanto sociedade por isso que
cada um de nós aqui hoje carrega uma
escola
eu acredito que precisamos ter altas
expectativas para todos e todas
tanto para alunos como para professores
é necessário a gente enxergar o
potencial de cada um um potencial que
vai além do pedagógico o potencial
humano
eu sou professora mas além de tudo eu
sou ser humano um ser humano que chora
que erra e aprende com seus erros e é
isso que eu busco nas crianças olhar
essa expectativa essas altas
expectativas e agregar o máximo que eu
posso para elas e como dizia vallon
afetividade ela faz parte do processo
cognitivo
eu vou dizer mais ela é fundamental
o amor o abraço o contato
o beijo é fundamental estar presente
eu não sou uma professora comum
eu recebo os meus alunos na porta da
sala de aula com muitos beijos e muitos
abraços por muitas vezes muitas pessoas
achavam isso fim como professor não pode
chegar perto do aluno não é essa relação
que fez tão dá certo o trabalho que
desenvolvo com essas crianças porque
afetividade ela precisa estar presente
afetividade ela faz parte da nossa
relação enquanto ser humano acreditar no
outro abraçar sentir-se amor é tão
necessário como sentir o amor de vocês a
hora que eu pisei nesse palco é isso que
faz a nossa vida diferente
é a gente poder acreditar hoje nós
estamos um papel de telespectadores
mas muito mais do que isso nós podemos
estar aqui hoje
modificando uma sociedade inteira
mostrando que o único caminho que de
fato transforma é educação
e quem aqui nunca vivenciou uma situação
de poder sair de fora e poder olhar essa
situação
do outro lado com os outros olhos e é
esse convite que eu quero fazer pra
vocês para que o momento vocês saiam de
uma situação enxergue a educação de um
outro olhar com outro viés com viés que
precisamos unir esforços que precisamos
olhar para os recursos que nós temos
para que de fato podemos transformar uma
sociedade educação ela pode ser sinônimo
de qualidade e equidade
mesmo quando precisamos mexer no lixo
essa foto é um dos protótipos meus
alunos realizaram com material
totalmente retirado das ruas é o olhe é
o símbolo da sustentabilidade
mas não é só o símbolo da
sustentabilidade é o símbolo da
transformação de olhar para o material
pra olhar para o recurso que nós temos e
poder falar
os recursos podemos fazer grandes coisas
principalmente quando a gente fala de
tecnologia
as pessoas têm a falsa ilusão que pra
trabalhar tecnologia a gente precisa ter
altos recursos e auto recursos não não
de fato não garante o conhecimento é
esse pertencimento que vai gerar então
esse conhecimento olhar para esse lixo
olhar para essa sucata me deu a
possibilidade de transformar a vida das
crianças
mas eles não fazem idéia do quanto eles
transformaram a minha vida do quanto
eles me fizeram ser uma professora
melhor quando eles acreditaram na
proposta de trabalhar e de poder de fato
intervir na sociedade
é isso que faz a diferença na educação é
essa vontade
essa diferença de poder transformar
aquilo que nós temos e eu não poderia
deixar de citar paulo freire e uma das
suas famosas frases ele diz o seguinte
educação não transforma o mundo a
educação muda pessoas pessoas muda o
mundo
o meu convite para vocês hoje é que
vocês sejam essa transformação que vocês
possam transformar esse mundo
vou em frente o mundo é de vocês muito
obrigado obrigado